well red tide has come to an end for
better or worse and if you haven't heard
my comments on that definitely check out
my episode 6 breakdown but it's time to
move on to death valley a four episode
mini-series with a focus on aliens so
we're gonna dive right into the preview
and if you haven't checked it out i've
left a link to it in the description but
come on back because i am so very lonely
here we see a military caravan escorting
what seems to be president dwight d
eisenhower across a desert landscape of
course i immediately get area 51 vibes
the title of this episode is take me to
your leader a double entendre referring
to the president of the free world as
well as the good ol alien saying now
when i was downloading this preview the
title said it was for episode 7 but
since it wasn't from an official source
there is the small possibility the
images here are from any of the next
four episodes notice here the black and
white imagery to fall in line with that
time period which if it falls under
eisenhower's presidency could be any
time between 1953 and 1961 the military
seems to have stumbled upon something
and my mind immediately jumps to that of
a ufo since we'll be seeing the military
operate on an alien later on but stick
with me for a bit because i think there
is something more surprising we'll fast
forward to what appears to be present
day and a group of teens on a trip down
a deserted road i wonder if it's the
same road the president took decades
earlier they're blasted by what could be
an alien beam or maybe the show is
totally throwing us off and it's a
military light from a helicopter or
something else because they've strayed
into a top secret base we see this super
brief image of what appears to be an
alien coming out of a ship followed by
an animal cut perfectly in two here
we'll see that group of teens uncover an
entire field of similarly cut carcasses
you'll see they're also in swimsuits
here so maybe they're off to find some
hidden grotto well this could actually
be what eisenhower and the military have
found lily rape's character amelia
earhart whose plane went missing in the
pacific ocean while trying to
circumnavigate the globe in 1937. how
the heck did she show up now completely
naked in the desert notice also these
spirals on her back almost like crop
circles did the aliens abduct her and
now are sending her back to earth the
teens find some rock markings which
likely lead them to that swim hole
they're heading out to and here's our
first look at sarah paulson who plays
mamie eisenhower dwight eisenhower's
wife a shot of some wreckage here
perhaps amelia earhart's plane which is
being checked for radioactivity now this
i'm kinda lost on it looks like it could
be a phone cord and someone has
collapsed in the bathroom as you can
just make out a toilet in the reflection
up here not really sure what this
product is here it kind of looks like
cough syrup but if you know definitely
post it in the comments okay now we're
getting into some really interesting
stuff looks like dwight is here and we
aren't quite sure if he was the one who
killed these doctors and nurses or if
he's investigating regardless it looks
like amelia is unharmed in the double
feature part 1 and 2 promo video that fx
released a few weeks ago we can see this
brief glimpse of amelia's x-ray which
sets us in 1954. i'll be referencing
this promo a lot going forward and i'll
leave a link to that in the description
this is a very weird shot of a toy fire
truck being beamed into the air
everything is really small here which
suggests it could be a miniature town a
woman shields herself from the wind and
light emanating from outside her home
this matches this shot here from the
other promo and if i were to guess this
is the same woman who gets possessed
later on here's an alien being dissected
and we hear dwight eisenhower say the
line i'm sure we can reach an
understanding it appears as though he's
talking to this woman but the editing is
a bit sneaky here listen to her say it
is you mr president who will listen to
us as she levitates toward him see if
you can hear the underlining sound of a
man's voice perhaps someone who is
controlling her it is you who will
listen to us
it is you who will listen to us
in the other promo this woman tells the
military her goal is to make something
better part human and part whatever she
is we need to create something better
part human
part us there's another voiceover line
here where an unknown woman says time is
running out for both of us this could
suggest the aliens and humanity need to
team up together for some unknown reason
still no word if the cold war will come
into play here as well here we have an
alien hand appear behind a blonde woman
perhaps this blonde woman is marilyn
monroe we know someone will be playing
the famed actress in the upcoming season
but in this shot here it looks as though
the government is either kidnapping or
killing her okay here we have some blood
dripping down not sure if it's from this
hospital scene earlier on and a close-up
of a young boy looking at something this
looks like kaya gerber's character who
plays a woman named kendall it looks
like she's getting injected with some
sort of ray gun by a man in a suit
probably the government this is really
cool mamie eisenhower floating if it's
anything like the other floating woman
we saw it seems as though these aliens
can take control of humans kendall
inspects this guy's stomach giving me
huge alien chestburster scene vibes and
this is followed by a doctor getting his
face sucked by some sort of alien blob
again just like alien on the autopsy
table is an alien not sure if this is
the same one who appears to make contact
with marilyn monroe and it looks like
this encounter will be very bloody the
final shot is of this woman being thrown
up to the ceiling in her home i wonder
if it's the same woman from here and
also the one who gets controlled you
know at first i wasn't too interested in
death valley but the more i'm starting
to fit things together the more it peaks
my interest and i think it's going to be
very different what are your thoughts
for part 2 i want to hear them in the
comments below thanks for watching
everyone make sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you